a historic brand is coming back to the
las vegas strip caesars entertainment
announcing ballies will soon be
rebranded as horseshoe las vegas joe
mohler live outside bally's with more on
the big changes joe
we all know the valley's name and
visitors when they come to town they
know exactly where it is here on the las
vegas strip well soon this popular
corner will look a lot different
the horseshoe brand is coming back you
may remember it from the binions
horseshoe in downtown las vegas
construction on the new casino will
begin this spring there will be a
multi-million dollar transformation of
ballet's casino floor a renovated
exterior and new entertainment and food
options senior vice president jason
gregerick says more announcements are to
come as you look at the property in
general you're going to see more
improvements popping up throughout the
property and a lot of them we can't
announce yet very exciting but over the
coming months you'll see and then as you
look at the exterior a nice refined
finish exterior new signage the iconic
horseshoe brand right now bally's
employs around a thousand people
gregorick says they will be actively
hiring throughout the process as well
some visitors like paula lloyd were
excited to hear the old name i'll
probably maybe stay here just because i
want to see
what happened
back out here live a bulk of the
renovations will be done by the end of
this year according to greg rick there
but on the exterior at the bottom here
at the strip there is also the grand
bazaar shops they'll be renovating that
as well that will go into next year one
restaurant was announced earlier this
last year that was it was the old red
that is also nashville owned by blake
shelton reporting live here on the strip
john muller live local now